مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا في موجز من قناه
الجزيره قال وزير الدفاع الامريكيه ان
طائره مقاتله تمكنت من اسقاط المنقاد
الصني قباله السواحل ولايه كارولاينر
الجنوبيه وكانه تجري حاليا عمليه انتشار
حطاما بنطاد من مياه البحر واضافنا
المنطاد استعمل من قبل الصين في محاوله
لمراقبه مواقع استراتيجيه
بدوره اكد رئيس الوزراء الكنديه دعم بلاده
قرار الولايات المتحده اسقاط ما سماه
منطاد المراقبه الصيني واضاف ان كندا
ستواصل مع قياده الدفاع الجوي لامريكا
الشماليه حمايه اجواء القاره حسب تعبيره
عربه الخارجيه الصينيه عن استيائها ازاءه
واصفته باستخدام الولايات المتحده القوه
في اسقاط المناطيد المدنيه واعتبرت
الوزاره اسقاط المنطاد انتهاكا خطيرا
للاعراف الدوليه وقالت ان التصرف الامريكي
ينذر بتداعيات
قال المستشار الالماني الى هناك توافقا مع
الرئيس الاوكراني فلادي على تجنب استخدام
الاسلحه القادمه من الغرب لشن هجمات على
الاراضي الروسيه وقال تشوبس في مقابله
صحفيه ان هناك اجماعا بهذا الخصوص
قال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي لمترم ان
امداد اوكرانيا بمزيد من الاسلحه
الامريكيه سيزيد العمليات الانتقاميه
الروسيه وتوعت بان الرد الروسي سيكون
سريعا وقاسيا اذا تعرضت شبه جزيره القرم
وعمق الاراضي الروسيه للقصف وقال ان روسيا
مستعده لاستخدام جميع انواع الاسلحه بما
في ذلك النوويه
يدخل اليوم حظر استيراد المنتجات
البتروليه الروسيه اذا الاتحاد الاوروبي
حيز التنفيذ وكان الحظر تقرر في يونيو
حزيران الماضي في اطار حزمه العقوبات
السادسه التي فرضها الاتحاد الاوروبي على
روسيا بسبب الحرب
اتهمت كل من الولايات المتحده وفرنسا
وبريطانيا والمانيا الحكومه الايرانيه
بعدم الوفاء بالتزاماتها بموجب اتفاقيه
حظر انتشار الاسلحه النوويه واشار بيانو
رباعي مشترك الى ان تقرير الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه افاد بان طهران عدلت سرا
منشاه فوردو لانتاج اليورانيوم عالي
التخصيب
في المقابل قال كبير المفاوضين الايرانيين
علي باقلي ان طهران التزمت بتعهداتها
الوارده في الاتفاق النووي وتتوقع ان
تتعامل الاطراف الاخرى بالطريقه نفسها
واضاف ان بلاده لن تبقى مكتوفه الايدي
ازاء عدم التزام الاطراف الاخرى بالاتفاق
وكان وزير بل رئيس منظمه الطاقه الذريه
الايرانيه محمد الاسلامي قال ان الموقف
السياسيه التي تتبناها الوكاله الدوليه
لطاقه الذريه بشان بلاده الناتجه عن ضغوط
انتهى هذا الموجز شكرا لكم واينما كنتم في
اماننا
[موسيقى]